joining me now is Paul marrow he's
inspector uh for the New York C former
head of intelligence operations for the
NYPD he's also an attorney uh Paul you
hear those words those are on American
college campuses the part we didn't get
to in talking with Cameron and Jim on
assessing the threat here in the United
States right is how everyone talks about
a credible threat well someone who is
stating their intentions to you I would
think would satisfy the requirement of a
threat being credible so this is the
dynamic that's changed here well
previously Hamas was not considered a
domestic threat here in the country
their Charter is pretty much limited to
taking the land back from Israel period
and the story what they're looking to do
now is to become a Force multiplier by
lashing on themselves to forces here in
the United States and globally they're
trying to enlarge their footprint to get
support unfortunately history has shown
us recent history that they have a soft
target here academically in the academic
world and that's why you're seeing this
stuff being played out on campuses
they're creating a lot of buzz on the AC
in in Academia because they've done this
very clever thing anti-israel forces
have lashed themselves up with what I
call the 1619 wing of the democratic
party they've made common cause and
position themselves as the oppressed and
they've lashed on to that narrative and
that just makes them a lot bigger player
globally that's why they're calling it
Hamas doesn't normally do this kind of
thing Global Jihad so what does it look
we want to stress no credible threats as
you said my old shop NYPD Intel is in
the best position of anybody to put a
finger on that and they put out a
statement they're looking at all their
sources they're looking online they're
doing all the things that they do so far
no credible threat but what I fear is as
the images start to come out okay now we
know the Israelis have done what they've
cut the water the power the internet
they've locked down the Food Supplies
and they're going in it's going to be
bloody it's going to be ugly Hamas wants
those images there's a reason Hamas just
stood up an app they want to take the
Isis route they want to win the
propaganda War they're all I'm not going
to say where the stuff is they're
already putting out videos that look
like very slick Isis videos those are
recruitment videos and they're looking
to get that globally make them a bigger
player that's the risk for American law
enforcement yeah the Border all the
other things we've seen in the past and
the border is a new Vector in this thing
I'm not downplaying that just a number
of Venezuelans coming in you know that
the former vice president of Venezuela
has a hesb of footprint the former vice
president you know what he's looked that
for by the American government giving
false passports to wait for it Hamas and
Hezbollah you know there's a ro reasons
why that Hamas and islamist
organizations have made their way into
Academia not not without the fact that
the Soviet Union backed to Arab states
against the Israeli state for many years
so it's part and parcel with the
far-left in the communist movement and
it's evidenced by what we all saw
earlier this week with BLM Chicago's
chapter putting out full-throated
support for Hamas not Palestine they put
put a paraglider on the image so full
threaded support for Hamas the question
is whether or not there's a credible
threat is have they been successful in
inspiring and by the looks of these
images in the United States you would
think they've inspired at least hatred
hopefully not more in in terms of action
the hatred is there undeniably and as I
said when we start to see the prop uh
propaganda war going full-throated and
we're going to period end the story
you're going to start to see the anger
really start to
and what that becomes when they start to
see those images is the justification
and that L I brought a ton of these
cases I know the dynamic you're going to
get people in many instances who are
leading slipping down lives we used to
call it loser lion all right somebody
who doesn't have a lot to lose
protesting they're not feeling gratified
enough and they decide that the term is
kinetic they decide to go kinetic very
very tough to interdict understand what
we're talking about here this is not
normal law enforcement where you're
coming in after the fact to figure out
where you know here's the body who did
the killing this is prophylactic you're
ahead of the game you're trying to
prevent it in a free Society with a
First Amendment that's a very gray area
it has to be heavily lawyered you have
to move very cautiously it's very
difficult and that's why it's not a a
zero sum game you're not going to get
them all and I know you've laid this out
you have a new piece in the Wall Street
Journal people should check that out
will you lay out these threats to the
Homeland do thank you so much thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else